it took 12 weeks that have now been the
outbreak is that sexy and we won the
number of
[Music]
people have access to accurate health
information and resources on copied
19:00 today I'm pleased to announce that
we have partnered with Facebook and
preclude dot-org to provide double H's
kovat 19 information in 3 basics and
discover in a mobile-friendly format
through this collaboration we will reach
some of the most vulnerable people who
will be able to access life-saving
health information without any data
charges in more than 50 countries we
have launched this product in English
French Spanish and Arabic and other
languages will fall
in the coming weeks furthermore I want
to thank Google for its continued
support and dedication to keep the
global community safe and informed and
for it recently increased I'd grant to
whu-oh this support enables us to catch
trending falsehoods early respond to
them quickly and give people better
access to life-saving information when
they need it most
wherever they are in the world this
pandemic has shown the importance of
being able to see each other online
while being physically apart and 20
years on from the Durbin AIDS Conference
a game-changing moment in the fight
against HIV leaders policymakers
scientists activists and civil society
are assembling virtually this week for
AIDS 2020 WH er is deeply concerned
about the impact of kovat 19 on the
global response to HIV a new whi survey
showed access to HIV medicines has been
significantly curtailed as a result of
the pandemic 73 countries have reported
that they're at risk of stock-outs of
antiretroviral medicines RV's to
mitigate the impact of the pandemic on
treatment access whi recommends all
countries prescribe a RV's for longer
periods of time up to 6 months while
supply chains for all medicines are
fully functioning
similarly shortages of condoms and pre
exposure prophylaxis can prove costly
and whu-oh calls for countries to ensure
uninterrupted prevention testing and
treatment services for HIV the
disruptions in access to life-saving
commodities and services come at a
critical
moment as progress in the global
response to HIV stalls over the last two
years numbers of new HIV infections
stabilized at 1.7 million annually and
there was only a modest reduction in
aids-related deaths more than 25 million
people now have access to a RVs but
global targets for prevention testing
and treatment are off target progress is
stalling because HIV prevention and
testing services are not reaching the
groups that need them most and the lack
of optimal HIV medicines with suitable
pediatric formulations has been a
long-standing barrier to improving
health outcomes for children living with
HIV going forward
access to services for vulnerable groups
must be expanded through stronger
community engagement improved service
delivery and tackling stigma and
discrimination 20 years ago Nelson
Mandela closed the AIDS conference by
saying I caught this is as I understand
it a gathering of human beings concerned
about turning around one of the greatest
threats of humankind has has faced I
will repeat I caught this is as I
understand it a gathering of human
beings concerned about turning around
one of the greatest threats humankind
has faced and of course those words from
Madiba echoed through a generation of
activists and policy makers alike and I
say them today as a message to the world
more than six months in the case for
national unity and global solidarity is
undeniable
to beat the covet 19 pandemic and ensure
that essential health services for
diseases like HIV continue we cannot
afford any divisions I will say it again
national unity and global solidarity are
important more than ever before to
defeat a common enemy a virus that has
taken the world hostage this is our only
road out of this pandemic
I repeat national unity and solidarity I
thank you thank you very much dr. Ted
Ross will now open the floor to
questions I would there are hundreds
many many of you with your hands up so I
would remind you one question each
please keep it short say your name and
where you're from and when I call on you
please remember to unmute yourself then
go ahead so our first question is from
Christine Theodore ooh from ABC network
USA Christine you have the flow please
go ahead hi I wanted to ask about the
New York Times report previewing an open
letter to be published by 239 scientists
from around the world calling for the
w-h-o to give greater acknowledgment to
the risk of an airborne spread of Koba
19 first of all I wanted to get your
reaction to those reports and to see
what where WH OHS research stands in
terms of what I'm where we are thank you
for your question
so we have discussed and collaborated
with many of the signatories of the
articles that you have mentioned over
the last few months
and indeed we discussed the available
evidence that has been discussed in this
piece
and also we received contributions from
many of the signatories of these pieces
we acknowledge that there is emerging
evidence in this field as in all other
fields regarding the copied 19:00 virus
and pandemic and therefore we believe
that we have to be open to this evidence
and understand its implications
regarding the modes of transmission and
also regarding the precautions that need
to be taken would you like to add
something Maria just to say that yes you
know we have been engaged with this
group since April when they first wrote
to us on April 1st and we've had an
active engagement with them and with
many of the signatories on this through
through different networks and as we
have said previously we welcome the
interaction from scientists all over the
world from many different disciplines
many of the signatories are engineers
which is a wonderful area of expertise
which which adds to growing knowledge
about the importance of insulation which
we feel also is very important we have
been talking about the possibility of
airborne transmission and aerosol
transmission as one of the modes of
transmission of kovat 19 as well as
droplet we've looked at fomites we look
at fecal-oral we look at mother-to-child
we look at animal to human of course as
well and so we are producing a
scientific brief on summarizing where we
are we've been working on this for
several weeks now and we've engaged with
a large number of groups epidemiologists
and clinicians IPCC specialists
engineers mathematical modelers to try
to consolidate the growing knowledge
around around transmission but we have
spoken about the the importance of all
of the different potential modes of
transmission this is a respiratory
pathogen and so it is important that
what we know fits into the guidance that
we
have which is why a comprehensive
package of interventions are required to
be able to stop transmission this
includes not only physical distancing it
includes the use of masks where
appropriate in certain settings
specifically where you can't do physical
distancing and especially for health
care workers so our focus on on the use
of mass of courses for healthcare
workers and to use airborne precautions
where you have those aerosol generating
procedures but we're also looking at the
possible role of airborne transmission
in other settings where you have
particularly close settings where you
have poor ventilation so we will be
issuing our brief in in the coming days
and that will outline everything that we
have in this area
thank you very much dr. saligan see and
van kick off the next journalist with a
question is yoga me launch of air FA
Jeremy please go ahead yes thank you so
much can you give me yes please go ahead
please thanks I will ask my question in
French if I may it's kind of a flow of
the previous question
did she keep in hospital Dalia esta aqui
todos lo EMS responders say this a
surely dog cycloalkane ugly truth Dolan
said the future Amy compounds 24th of
July s-curve solutions mr. Paulo SK
Louis in Japan you do need the all
commodity ought to treat those are
context to NATO planning team to Cassio
set in circulation function but will you
be equally Iranian or s coz-theta
Akito Macy
Thank You Jeremy its dr. Ella currency
will answer your question so I'll answer
in English if it's okay so first of all
I would like to highlight that we
encouraged and supported research in
this field as well you highlighted the
hydroxychloroquine or the treatments
field of research but we have supported
research in this field as well and
indeed last week as you may remember we
held an international research meeting
where the we're active discussions on
infection prevention and control and
modes of transmission and our group
together with the experts who are part
of it really highlighted the importance
of research in the field of different
transmission routes and in particular
through droplets of different sizes and
understanding really what is the
relative importance of this and also
understanding the doze of of the virus
that is needed in particular in this
route of transmission that is the
aerosol or airborne transmission so
these are fields of research that are
really growing and for which there is
some evidence emerging but is not
definitive and therefore the possibility
of airborne transmission in in public
settings especially in very specific
conditions crowded closed poorly
ventilated settings that have been
described cannot be ruled out however
the the evidence needs to be gathered
and interpreted and we continue to
support this regarding the measures that
you were talking about
yes indeed we do recommend a number of
measures like those mentioned my by my
colleague before which take into
consideration this possibility in
several of our guidance documents we do
recommend as much as possible avoiding
closed settings and crowded situations
we do recommend appropriate and optimal
ventilations of indoor environments and
also physical distancing as you know and
when this is not possible in areas with
community transmission of the virus we
recommend the use of face masks in
particular fabric no medical masks for
the public so all of this is taken into
consideration in our recommendations as
we previously said so if I could just
add to that and just to say a few words
about how whu-oh does its normative work
the guidelines and the standards and the
recommendations that we make are based
on a process that we've had now well
established and of course we're
constantly improving that process we're
constantly looking for innovations and
how we can do better and when you are in
an emergency situation like we are and
when the science is constantly changing
on a daily basis almost you know we
review some days up to a thousand
publications the average is about 500
new publications a day so there's a huge
amount of new data that's being put out
not all of it is of good quality
it needs to go through peer review and
that takes time but we look at preprints
and we look at peer reviewed
publications we do what's called a
systematic review of the evidence it's
also sometimes called a meta-analysis
when you have a large number of studies
you put them together and have a
statistical method of of trying to see
where the evidence
is pointing in which direction and as
you know every study that comes out is
not always in agreement with the
previous one that's how science evolves
till you get a body of data so so you
have bio engineers and experts and
physics who do experiments in
laboratories and and and come out with
with that kind of data now whether that
exactly reflects what happens in day to
day settings in clinical settings we
cannot extrapolate right so you then you
have to take ecological descriptive data
sometimes from outbreaks that happen in
different settings which may point in a
certain direction but then you cannot
always rule out for example it may point
to the fact that they could have been
limited airborne transmission but it
could also be true for mites or other
means and so there's the body of
evidence continues to to grow and we
adapt and so we do what's called a
living systematic review every week we
update the review based on the latest
and there are hundreds of publications
now in the area of transmission and then
we have what's called a guideline
development group that considers all of
this evidence and many of the scientists
who are authors of that some of the
scientists for authors on that latter
part of our export groups and guideline
development groups and they didn't look
at the evidence and then they have to
make a considered recommendation and we
take this very seriously we are of
course focused on on public health
guidance and so any guidance that we put
out has implications of course for for
billions of people around the world so
it has to be carefully considered before
it is done so we want to be as fast as
possible and an adaptive and responding
to the new evidence and at the same time
we have to consider the weight of the
evidence and and you mentioned
hydroxychloroquine so very quickly I
think because we don't want to be the
reason that we interrupted that trial
was because safety of participants was
in question because of a publication
which later was withdrawn but we cannot
take a chance we cannot take a risk with
50 of people who are in a clinical trial
and so within a week when it was clear
that that there wasn't that evidence the
the study then restarted and as you know
you may know we we completed the
hydroxychloroquine arm and because
there's enough evidence now to show that
it does not have any impact on mortality
in hospitalized patients with covered so
just wanted to give you an idea of how
how whu-oh actually makes guidance and
it's it's not impulsive it's not done on
a day to day basis but it's a process
that continues and will continue I'm
sure with kovat for the weeks and months
to come thank you very much for those
comprehensive answers we now have a
question from Bianca
Rozier from Globo Brazil Bianca please
go ahead hi Margaret can you hear me
very well please go ahead
thanks a lot
yeah the brisbane president Abelson Lara
just announced that he tested positive
for corona virus and as you know in the
last month we have seen him calling
kovat 19i small flu ignoring the use of
masks and also criticizing social
distancing measures we would like to
hear from the w-h-o how important is it
that the leaders set an example to the
population in the fight again depend
emic and how dangerous is that
Brazilians feel lost in the middle of a
crisis like this one I'm sure dr. to
speak to this but we certainly wish mr.
well so now very well and we wish a
speedy and full recovery from from this
disease although leaders around the
world have had similar experiences I
think it brings home for us all the
reality of this virus and no one
is special in that regard we were all
potentially exposed to this virus the
virus citizens really know who we are
whether were Prince or pauper we are
equally vulnerable and I think what
really highlights is our collective
vulnerability to this disease
so we wish mr. Bolton and his family the
best in this regard it is a time in any
Brazil is a great nation the face is a
difficult difficult task in a difficult
time the numbers in Brazil have
stabilized over the last number of days
and certainly the reproductive number
across many of the states while it still
hovers above one yeah it has moved down
the however the hospital system still
remains under some pressure and while it
is still coping and again with great
regard to the skill and commitment of
health workers all over Brazil but
hospital occupancy and ICU bed occupancy
is still coping but it's it's in many
cases near critical so Brazil faces many
of those challenges we hope as I've said
here previously that Brazil can continue
to develop and deliver the response a
federal state and at local level that we
see the the unity of purpose and the
sustained application of the
comprehensive strategy that we have
abrogated for for a very very long time
and we trust that if Brazil can bring
all of its health system public health
system and its communities together that
Brazil can continue to make progress in
the face of this disease but I think the
message to us all is we are all
vulnerable to this virus thank you
I think my mic mic has said it all we
have been saying for a long time now
including at the early stages of the
pandemic that this virus is very
dangerous
and we called it many times public enemy
number one
this is ugly days it has two dangerous
combinations one it moves fast and also
it's a killer and that's why we were
worried and warning the world
continuously so as as Mike said I think
we are all vulnerable and that's why we
also say this is an enemy against
humanity that humanity should stand in
unison to fight to fight and defeat it
this happens what is in a century
it's a dangerous virus none like this
has been seen since the since 1918 and
national unity I said it in my speech
and global solidarity are the most
important and without which without
which and without which I don't think we
can defeat this virus and the divisions
actually will be advantage to the virus
and not only Brazil the whole Latin
America doesn't look good cases are on
the rise deaths are on the rise and even
North America Mesoamerica except Canada
Canada is doing better we are concerned
and in the rest of the world although I
said the deaths are leveling off because
some countries are showing some progress
but many countries are actually having
more cases and deaths are on the rise so
it's very important to understand the
seriousness of this this virus and to be
really serious no country is immune and
no country is safe and no individual can
be safe but having said this we wish his
Excellency the president well and we
wish him fast recovery and I hope I hope
the symptoms will be mild and his
Excellency will be back back to office
as soon as possible to support his
country thank you thank you dr. Ted Rose
for those supportive words and we do
know we are all vulnerable we have a
journalist on the line trying to get
through Cameron Kasimov who has been
trying to call us from his hospital bed
because he in Azerbaijan has also been
diagnosed with kovat everyone is
vulnerable
I will ask his question for him later if
he can't get through but we will now go
to image and Fuchs
from the BBC image and please unmute
yourself and go ahead it is to do with
the the death rate because I think on
Friday dr. treacherous you said that the
death rate peaked in April and since
then we have millions of more cases and
no you that the death rate is still
rising in some countries but it isn't in
others which would still have a heavy
burden of cases could you kind of break
it down a bit more for us what you
tribute that tomb is it the age of the
people who are getting the virus is it
that better better way of treating
Imogen you broke up did you get can you
repeat the last it was okay because
initials have developed a better way of
treating it they know more about it I'm
just I'm interested in a breakdown of
why the death rate isn't rising as fast
as this cases thank you thank you about
that is I will I will give it to my
colleagues to say more but when I said
last time about the peak in April it was
about Sweden actually it picked the week
of April 20 and ever since the number of
deaths in Sweden actually has been on
the decline of course the number of
cases has been on the increase even
until the week of June 22 in in Sweden
and I said of course we worry about
increased number of cases but more
important is you know watching on the
number of deaths even if the number of
cases increased if we managed to reduce
the number of deaths that would be very
important and that's why I cited Sweden
as an example and there are other
countries whose death rate is actually
on the decline
and that's why overall this deserts
number of deaths globally has actually
leveled off but that doesn't mean that
it's a success because the leveling off
of number of deaths globally is because
of some countries
but in many countries it's on the rise
and that's why we said even if the
number of cases are increasing we have
to focus especially on the number of
deaths and we need to have targeted
approach to reduce the number of deaths
and many countries have found that the
deaths are disproportionately higher in
older age age groups and other
vulnerable groups and when they started
their targeted approach especially in
long term facilities the death started
to decline so that focused approach will
be very important and that's what we are
we're suggesting based on the experience
from countries that manage to lower
deserts like Sweden but another example
is I think we have said it before Japan
even though the number of cases were
high especially at the initial stage of
the pandemic but the number of deaths
were kept kept really low and this was
because Japan was focused in targeted
intervention to save lives and many
countries can follow that targeted
approach which can help to keep the
deserts low and the April peak which I
say it was about Sweden which ever since
has actually declined in in in Sweden
thank you just as a general rule of
thumb of you go back to April we were
probably averaged around 6,000 deaths
per day globally and that sort of stayed
pretty steady and has dropped in sort of
mid May to around 5,000 deaths per day
and it's gone up and down slightly
around that number and it's kate's kind
of state very steady as the DG is said
all within that there are countries with
increasing debts and countries with
decreasing debts what has happened
though at the same time if you imagine
again back in April we were around
80,000 cases a day 66 thousand deaths in
in March about a hundred eighty to a
hundred thousand cases and there again
around five to six thousand deaths and
then in May into beginning of June very
similar well what we've seen in the
month of June is an acceleration in the
number of cases and what hasn't
accelerated with that yet are the number
of deaths but if we know it takes time
and there is a lag phase and that so
some of this may be like we may see
deaths start to climb again because
we've only really experienced this rapid
increase in cases over the last five to
six weeks so we may see that so I don't
think it should be a surprise if the
deaths start to rising it would be very
unfortunate but it may happen there is
an element certainly of better care and
again doctors and nurses and physicians
have really learned how to better manage
this case simple stuff from oxygen
therapy to prom therapy managing
patients picking out those patients who
were likely to deteriorate more rapidly
by looking at oxygen levels in the blood
so essentially managing the clinical
pathways so the patient's most likely to
get very sick get into the highest form
of care quickly so that the clinical
pathway has been managed more
effectively has probably had an impact
on the overall number of deaths
certainly some of the therapies that
have become available may also have
reduced dead weights who seemed like
some dexamethasone and others that have
reduced the number of deaths and very
severe patients and in a number of those
factors there's also the testing factor
as testing has increased the proportion
of people maybe in younger age groups
who are being detected that we're not
detected before is increased so the
overall number of fatalities is a
smaller proportion of your world number
of cases that certainly has some impact
on that but we would expect the
proportion of positive cases as
total of the total number of cases to
drop at the same time which has happened
in many places so you're right Imogen it
is a it is a complex series of factors
what's good is that the death rate is
stable it may increase we would hope to
be able to collectively drive that what
is a concern is the fact that the
disease numbers are increasing day by
day and if you imagine that somewhere in
April and May we were dealing with a
hundred thousand cases a day today we're
dealing with two hundred thousand cases
a day and that is not purely as a result
of testing this epidemic is accelerating
and we're lucky I hope part of it is
that we've become better and there is a
difference between being good and being
lucky I would prefer to be both good and
lucky and but I do think Allah some of
this at least is down to some excellent
frontline doctors and nurses and their
ability to detect and treat patients
early and we hope we can continue to
provide them with the support they need
to keep pushing their curve down some of
it is also due to shielding and
protection of older populations who I
think we've learned all of us
collectively there's underlying
conditions that people in long-term care
facilities are particularly at risk and
therefore shielding and protecting more
vulnerable people and ensuring that
they're not infected or don't get
infected may also reduce in a reduction
in the overall number of deaths
thank you DT just just just a quick note
to say that while we're talking about
this in general there are quite some
differences by countries and we've
spoken many times about the challenges
of comparing mortality by country
because there are so many factors that
could be associated with these
differences and just calculating
mortality we're looking at deaths over
time that reported deaths over time and
if you look at deaths by million
population or if you look at a crude
case fatality ratio there are challenges
with all of these estimates which could
have to do with the surveillance
strategies and testing strategies of
finding cases have to do with X
to care early care access to oxygen etc
and and of course we are learning and
frontline workers are learning how to
care better for patients but it also is
affected by the populations that are
affected we've seen in some countries
the majority of the deaths are due to
cases that are identified in long term
living facilities this is that this has
been a tragic aspect of this pandemic
and something that can be tackled and
something that we could focus on and
make sure that we reduce we prevent the
opportunity to enter into these
vulnerable populations and then to just
to add that some countries will be
revising the the deaths as they go
forward and looking at attributing
deaths to Cova directly indirectly and
whatnot and and there are systems in
place in Europe for example the euro
Momo program which is looking at excess
mortality across Europe and there's
other systems in place in other parts so
it will take us some time to really
understand mortality but having said
that there are many things that we can
do now to prevent infections and by
preventing infections we are ultimately
preventing the opportunity for someone
to advance to severe disease and death
so that's this is a major focus of ours
and all of the member states to do as
much as we can as quickly as we can to
reduce mortality where possible DT okay
thank you I just wanted to add a few few
things one what we're saying is the
number of cases is on the increase it's
actually accelerating very very fast and
I i have already provided the figures
but it's still positive it's still
possible by using the comprehensive
approach to minimize transmission and we
have to focus on that but what we're
saying is we have to be even more
focused and we have to do more to save
lives to minimize mortality and many
countries are doing that and that's why
it's leveling off and we have to invest
on that but one more thing I would like
to say is
on the Americas like to say that
especially the Caribbean countries are
doing very well both in terms of
suppressing transmission and also in
terms of saving saving lives but not
only the Caribbean the Pacific countries
are also doing doing well and there are
some positive or good progress in some
parts of the world too but overall we're
really concerned as I said earlier thank
you very much that question stimulated a
really rich discussion we're running out
of time I'm sorry if there are so many
of you on the line but we've only got
time for two more questions so I'll now
go to Kai kuba Schmitt thanks thanks for
taking my question
I was wondering just to go back to the
announcement of the you know
sorry scouting team to go to China for
the look at zoonotic transmission can
you give a little bit of an idea of what
are the kind of things that you would
hope to achieve there what are the kind
of things that you would hope you can
look at would you be trying to go to you
know industrialized farming you know
really try to to get a sense of the
animal human interface that might exist
or are you going to concentrate on who
Han where the first cases were I
realized that all of this is part of
what you want to decide in that advance
mission but I'm just curious what you
hope to get out of it Thanks these
issues quite closely over time and I
think first of all you and many
scientific journals know that the the
answers and these questions are
sometimes elusive and it's quite a
detective story to find the source and
the intermediate pathways by which the
virus can can breach that barrier to
humans
we spent decades trying to do that in
Ebola we spent years trying to do that
with MERS and SARS it takes time and it
does take a meticulous multi-sectoral
approach to this so there is the Wild
Animal Kingdom there is the farmed
animal kingdom then there are the
interfaces with humans those interfaces
with humans can occur with wild animals
they can occur on farms they can occur
in markets and we don't know where that
species barrier was actually breached
and I think our colleagues in in China
or our scientific colleagues are equally
anxious to find answers to that because
this is very important because unless we
understand like anything if the walls of
your castle are breached you need to
know where the breach is because you can
fix and repair that breach you can make
sure that that is strengthened for the
future so we need to understand what was
the the track of this virus from the
wild animal kingdom directly into humans
directly through farmed animals directly
into a market one market to how many so
understanding that that story
understanding that the narrative and the
pathway by which this virus entered the
human population is extremely important
but it's not always a straightforward
process of being able to get that answer
I know that sounds obtuse but there are
many dead ends when you study these
things and I've you know we've seen that
as I said we spent many years trying to
look at the source for Ebola and the
intermediate hosts and we still even in
Ebola have difficulties with the
intermediate hosts we understand that
the primary host is in bath but then
there are many potential intermediate
hosts that have been having Maria can
speak tumors we and Sarah's and many
other diseases for which she has a deep
experience I do think though when we and
we will be working very closely as we
did in previous missions with Chinese
colleagues number one the there is a
both the Ministry of Science and
Technology the Ministry of Health will
be involved in this and we look forward
to a deep engagement with them with the
scientific community in China first of
all to set out what the approach will be
what investigations need to be carried
out where do these investigations need
to be carried out
what the a they should be collected and
what what date is already available
because very often in these situations
some of the data is there already you
need to look at that days or what's
available then you need to decide is
that enough data to make a determination
both epidemiologic data laboratory days
and animal data and then you decide
based on that date of whether further
investigations are needed and where
those investigations or leaders needed
and Tetris was often said to me the
invest those sorts of investigations
lead where they lead there is a trail
and we have to follow that but the best
place to start is is clearly in in in in
where their disease emerged in humans
first and where the disease emerged in
humans first where the first clusters
were atypical pneumonia occurred where
Mohan so that is the best starting point
for an investigation of the of the
animal origin but after that I think we
have to keep an open mind science must
stay open to all possibilities and
therefore we need to lay out a series of
investigations that will get the answers
that I'm sure the Chinese government
governments around the world and
ourselves really need in order to manage
the risk going forward into the future
thank you thank you Mike and by the way
when we say Tim is going for the
preparations to China it doesn't mean
that China has not been researching on
this it doesn't mean that we will be
starting from from scratch because there
is capacity actually in China to do to
do research so as Mike said we will pick
up from what's already already done and
the planning of this team that's going
to be going for the planning with its
counterparts will of course consider
what has been done so far so we
shouldn't consider as if there was no
movement or no activity until now thank
you
thank you very much as I said we were
trying to get through to Cameron Kasimov
and unfortunately we have not been able
to get him so we wish him well and wish
him to as everyone else who's fighting
this virus and I'll just hand there is
also an important press conference on
HIV starting now
so I'll just hand it over to dr. Ted
Rose for final words thank you
Thank You Margaret and thank you also to
all those who have joined on on online
and look forward to seeing you on Friday
thank you so much